[Music]
I'm Dana Jacobson from CBS this morning
Saturday I'm here in Times Square which
isn't too far from our New York studios
now we know not everyone likes to get up
early on a Saturday morning to watch our
show so over the next half hour we're
going to share some of our favorite
pieces focusing on the arts but first my
co-host Jeff Glor takes an inside look
at a photographer in his journey from a
kid with a camera to photographing a
wolf on Sunset Boulevard
that's Mesa magic resist I've always
believed that the best photographers
stand in front of the most interesting
things it's really that simple
from the Arctic to Africa to the
American West
David Yarrow's work shooting wildlife
indigenous communities and landscapes
has reshaped fine art photography you
never know when that big Mel is going to
come a combination of his extreme
planning and patience that's it right
recently in Southern California yarrow
only had a few minutes of perfect
sunlight to create his latest print
shade right a staged shot on Sunset
Boulevard featuring one of the most
famous models in the world Alessandra
Ambrosio a car and a wolf here ambrosia
wasn't comfortable sitting next to the
wolf come on you're fine come on if you
don't like it we can shoot them
independently
yeah we just do a composite of the two
euro improvised you've got to get that
wolf further forward in the car you have
Sunset Boulevard shut down people
honking at you like crazy yeah a wolf
for walls for walls he brings backups
just in case the photo titled Chateau
Marmont was half of euros wolf of Wall
Street idea and homage to the Martin
Scorsese Leonardo DiCaprio film because
our clients are already answering the
phone you all know this scene wolf of
wallstreet he did one picture outside
and one inside a trading room
[Music]
with jordan belfort the man the wolf of
wallstreet is based on euros usual goal
is to get as close as possible to
animals of all kinds that includes
traveling to South Africa with British
model Cara Delevingne to shoot her in
front of a lion you search David Garrow
on the internet this is one of the first
ones that comes up I mean she's a
British icon she is authentic she is
brave she's fearless she is fearless
Yarrow has also come face to face with
Black Panthers elephants captured here
with a special wide-angle lens and
Tigers Tigers will kill you Tigers the
most vicious animals in the world they
will kill you for fun I'll go in the
cage I think and try and work from the
cage is there ever any fear this fear of
failure which is always good but it fear
of personal safety never with animals
with people yes I mean my scary moments
have always been with people because
people can buy weed they can get drunk
and they can buy guns our animals can't
do those three things one of euros most
famous photos is a kind of selfie with a
polar bear where if you look closely you
can see his silhouette in the Bears eyes
I heard somebody say once that most
people survive attacks with black bears
or Grizzlies but nobody's ever survived
an attack from a polar bear I think
that's probably probably true and yet
you're right there in its face well we
do worse than we do more than that
because they're very sweet tooth so
you've always got to be done you've got
to be downwind from them never be upwind
from the photo bear because they
wouldn't smell you but if you're
downwind and then you cover yourself in
chocolate but we always say don't don't
do it at home
David euro first became interested in
photography as a teenager snapping
pictures of sporting events in England
but following parental and economic
pressure he shifted to banking way back
in 1988 photography was something that
weird people did like they would be
trainspotters whereas banking is what
normal people do and now banking is what
weird people do at photography is what
normal people they're this maze
far we've come euro didn't get back to
photography full-time until 2012 by that
time his marriage had painfully fallen
apart I wasn't fond of myself my path to
redemption was to pick up my cameras and
go to the most remote parts of the world
that was the way that was my antidote my
personal pain euro has cultivated an
impressive list of celebrity fans by now
Tom Brady wrote the foreword to his
latest book when people want to say
something nasty about me they'll turn
right David yeah he's he's taking some
good pictures but you know he's a
businessman my mother was an artist
who's knew much better artist than me at
sculptures and she she died sadly
penniless because she thought they the
commercial pursuit or the monetization
of her craft was shameless I don't know
let's be shameless
let's just let's we've got it we've got
a van that's how you feel about it when
people say that there's more interest in
the celebrity or that were the business
part of it then the actual art itself I
think you have some of that market if
people want to if people want to turn
around and say yeah well what David
Yates he knows the American football
players and British football players and
supermoto whatever I work with them I
think you've done a remarkable job
Errol can take months to plan one
picture but once everything is in place
things move fast
from Sunset Boulevard to here yeah and
we pride ourselves on our work I think
we shot this twenty six hours ago and
here is the final version he then only
releases a limited number of original
sign pictures single prints can go for
well over $100,000 do you ever stop to
think about that that you're producing
pictures that they demand that amount of
money in 1985 I photograph Wimbledon I
go home I would print up my pictures in
the darkroom and I would sell them on
the streets
the next day for 20 quid a picture
so when you go from selling pitchers on
the street for 20 quid to seeing one of
your pitchers guess other means of
course you think about the fact that
your journey is as worked and your hard
work paid off
so that garnish do I go to bed thinking
about it no I just want to get better
time now to move from Hollywood to well
here my co-host Michelle Miller steps
into an off-broadway production rooted
in African culture if you've never seen
dance moves like this before
welcome to the stage
of death Africa the professional dance
company performs stepping an American
invention rooted in African tradition
born on black college campuses a century
ago second is an art form first
developed by african-american
fraternities and sororities that uses
the body as an instrument see Brian
Williams is its founder first time I saw
it was walking on campus at Howard
University
me too homecoming Sep show step show all
the Greeks
Williams pledge the oldest one Alpha Phi
Alpha fraternity I am a real man at
gamma man when you asked to speak but
then came 1988 and director Spike Lee's
film school days
that was a huge moment because for the
years that have been like the secret
this artform if you weren't around the
college campus you might miss it but
school days kind of brought it out and
from there stepping took off
Williams launched step Afrika in 1994
after hosting a festival celebrating the
election of Nelson Mandela in post
apartheid South Africa oh it was a wild
time I think which is young excited
wanted to do something different wanted
to bring these two cultures together but
it was his visit four years earlier that
truly set the stage I'm there in 1990
studying and working and that's where I
first saw the South African gumboot
dance and it looks so much like stepping
that I had to kind of do a little more
research on it and what did your
research find I found out it was an art
form created by men who worked in the
mines of South Africa and it was a
percussive dance
they used the body as an instrument just
like stepping in 25 years
Williams is taken stepping global
touring 49 states in more than 50
countries it's even got its own
interactive exhibit at the National
Museum of African American history and
culture every four minutes a young
person gets to learn how to step look
step Afrika and it's resonating in the
last two decades steppin has made its
way into music videos including a
Beyonce routine there's even a movement
to bring the platform to n-c-double-a
teen levels competition just about
everyone ATandT
tries to get in on the act
but on this circuit artistic director
Mathon OCH bun let me get the middle
manages 15 full time artist she joins
step Afrika 15 years ago it's the rhythm
within your body it's within your soul
you're gonna get different sounds in
different tones and different rhythms
from different parts of your bodies
things you wouldn't even you know snaps
and you know making stomps and clop yes
Oliver natural
I miss my call
this year's calling the national tour of
drum folk it's the company's second show
to run off Broadway in three years
drum folks the vision of historian dr.
David Pleasant and folklore especi Jones
seen through the lens of director Jakari
Sherman where does stepping come from
what happened when the drum was taken
away
drum folk traces the deep-seated roots
of stepping to an event in 1739 called
the Stono rebellion about 20 men from
angola rose up near the Stono River and
the colony of South Carolina they were
using drums as they went along and they
gathered gathered people by the end of
it was maybe a hundred people right it
lasted just a few days but the backlash
prompted even harsher slave laws
recognizing the power of the drum in
this insurrection the colony enforced
what became known as the Negro Act they
restricted the reading and writing they
restricted gathering they restricted
traveling and that's a good thing but
most importantly at our story they
restricted the use of the drum and the
drum is so tied to culture African
culture so so tied to so when that was
taken away the body became the drum for
step Afrika the drum has come full
circle what are you most surprised about
what blew your mind on this journey for
years I wanted to step in the White
House and I was like we need to be in
the East Wing under those chandeliers
and we didn't make those chandelier
shake so when President Obama was
elected I was like okay I may have to
make a move
it took eight years but in February of
2016
Williams's wish was granted step Afrika
made it to the East Room and the art
form of slaves was performed in the
house that slaves built that was
absolutely incredible you got that on
film oh yeah on the iPhone unless it's a
that but yeah we got it captured what
was the chandelier glycans clanking we
made we made them soon
[Applause]
like so many other things step Afrika
shows are on hold right now but they do
have performances scheduled for later in
the year
time now to fly south to Miami where
Kenneth Craig gives us a look at a
museum like no other
looking at that train that was the
summer of 1980 when I was 23 that New
York City subway was one of more than
5,000 that graffiti artist Steve Auburn
covered in color captured in photos now
on display at the new Museum of graffiti
and you're doing this in the middle of
the night this is a two o'clock in the
morning
pitch dark standing like this next door
train you got to a point where you
became a master an expert in New York
City subways well in the in the tunnels
because I could really run really fast
that's six feet tall probably 139 pounds
29 inch waist I mean I could move for me
it's so nice because someone's
recognizing it known as blade he was
part of the birth of modern graffiti in
the 70s and 80s and is considered one of
its pioneers among a generation of
daring young writers whose works are
featured here your intention was what
when you set up the design of the museum
to bring you through a historical
timeline to show you from the very
beginning of the style writing movement
the graffiti art movement till today
Allen ket is a graffiti artist historian
and collector who partnered with former
state prosecutor Allison Frieden as she
was doing advocacy work for graffiti
writers the duo co-founded the museum
not only to educate the public and
preserve the history but to provide
visitors a counter narrative that was
really the goal for both Allen and I is
to sing the song of unsung heroes who
have contributed so much to our culture
yet the artists who pioneered that were
routinely shunned for their
there was a war on graffiti for four
decades there was a war on graffiti for
decades but what does that even mean
that just means you're cleaning it up
that means that you're incarcerated
young kids and perhaps exposing them to
real criminals and real criminal
activity in real criminal life ket's
illegal run-ins over his work landed him
a number of lawsuits done and in 2007 a
plea deal with New York City prosecutors
that made headlines there still will be
people who will watch this and say
that's not art that's vandalism you know
and I think that those folks that that
say that should come and visit us and
take a walk with me so that I could
explain to you why this is in our form
and how this art form was created and
how it's evolved and developed and gone
around the world and how it now sells
for millions of dollars then you see
gesture to the right his J kicks up and
creates a big circle it's what he's now
doing inside the collection in the early
80s and out on the streets where the
museum has commissioned 11 murals we
walk by and we see police they're
looking for the artist it's nighttime
they're using flashlights the
institution opened in Miami's Winwood
neighborhood a former industrial
district that over the past decade
street artists have transformed into a
vibrant and massive open-air gallery
here aerosol artists from around the
world have free reign
Wynwood really has become a destination
here in Miami
Wynwood is an art destination in Miami
it's also an entertainment destination
it's a foodie destination there's all
kinds of things happening here it's a
nightlife destination the 3200 square
foot museum is packed with more than 300
pieces of the movements history and the
artists behind it and I started on buses
artists like Blade who's trailblazing
work earned him the title the king of
graffiti did you ever think this day
would come
no of course not because it's an art
form created by young people for young
people and when I started there were no
masterpieces they're going Holkar top to
bottom and
and some of the artifacts are from Alan
ket's personal archive for him
the museum's opening and the celebration
that followed was the ultimate
validation when you grow up as a child
and your parents tell you that this is
something wrong and then when you go to
school and your teachers are telling you
this is wrong you're gonna be a loser
for the rest of your life and society
finally catches up to celebrate you it's
incredibly moving it's an emotional
experience you know you never think that
you'd make it to a place that finally
got it Kenneth Craig Miami we close with
art of a different sort the art of
educating our young people here's my
story on 50 years of Sesame Street it
began as an experiment a TV show to
level the educational playing field for
all preschool children I always learn
when I watch you guys isn't that the
best when you play and have fun and you
learn 50 years later Sesame Street is
still around how are you guys
celebrating where am i celebrating by
learning how to count to 50 yeah Elmo's
up to four I was just gonna go to 47
you're almost there Elmo
that's so close 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 over the
last half century Sesame Street has had
the same goal to make kids smarter
stronger and kinder I said I'm sorry I
made you angry and we got in a fight I
won't do it again can we still be
friends and that's not all
Sesame Street from the very beginning
has adopted playful learning as its
approach to teach Rosemarie Truglio is
in charge of curriculum and content at
Sesame Workshop the nonprofits behind
the groundbreaking show why have you
children learn
easily from an Elmo or a Cookie Monster
because Elmo and Cookie are their
friends and so there's this word that we
use in developmental psychology it's
called this power social relationship
when children watch Sesame Street and
they see Elmo and Big Bird and Julia and
Abby they're they're friends
they're real they talk they eat they
sleep they cry they're real and when you
develop that connection you're gonna
learn more from a character that you
care about take Cookie Monster thank you
are we done showing word resistant house
or in yes yes the most impulsive Muppet
on Sesame Street no can resist go get
any more cool gay kids watching cookie
fail they're learning
hey he messed up eat the cookie that
strategy didn't work the fused another
strategy and the next time you use that
stretches it won't start so it's
important for us to show that trial and
error
those same Muppets are also the best
choice to explain difficult realities
my dad's in jail like incarceration we
don't have our own apartment anymore
homelessness and autism SME magic is
they take difficult topics and put them
through the lens of a child so that it's
very easy to understand
Teresa Fitzgerald heads up branding she
and her team spent years creating julia
a muppet who's on the autistic spectrum
we were just going to create a storybook
and we created character art for a
storybook okay and it was so well
received that they decided to build the
puppet so we took those drawings and
went to Henson and Henson created a
puppet so that translation there's a lot
of creative decisions made and then she
appeared on the show Julia and Big Bird
see her painting and then this year we
just added her family what was the
response when she first appeared on the
show it's amazing it really was there
was such a need that there was such a
positive response but it's more than
feedback research shows that Sesame
Street has a positive impact on kids
this paper on early childhood education
found access to the show was associated
with better elementary school
performance they compared the Sesame
viewers to non viewers on average they
performed 16% higher than the non
viewers but they also had these positive
dispositions towards learning much more
motivated to learn and engage in leisure
reading and better pro-social skills as
well so it wasn't just the academic it
also had a social impact Sesame Street
continues to strive for that impact by
using everything from apps
two books including rosemarie true Leo's
new book Sesame Street ready for school
working with children alone is not the
answer because children are learning
from the adults around them you're
teaching children you're also teaching
parents I often say I wish parents would
watch Sesame Street as a parenting show
because we have a human cast who's
really representing them as a parent
feelings pass and feelings change
feelings pass and feelings and so when
our characters are struggling with an
emotion or they're dealing with the
problem the human cast is basically
telling and showing us as parents how we
could possibly address this with our
child learning for all ages and lessons
for everyone is it any wonder 50 years
after Sesame Street was created people
are still asking
[Music]
like we like that we all different
colors we even have a grouch another
language and we only really happy
together yeah it's a great lesson for
all of us true when you David go get
some cookies I like okay everybody
cookies if you enjoyed any of those
stories be sure to watch Jeff Michelle
and me every Saturday from 7:00 to 9:00
on CBS this morning Saturday and four
news 24/7 right here cbsn free on most
platforms thanks for joining us take
care of each other